Welcome to part three of the course.
Uh, this is going to be about cosmology.
One of the most amazing thing that's
happened over the past half century or so
is that cosmology, which is, uh,
the study of the universe as a whole,
uh,
has become a scientific subject.
Uh,
and something that one can say something
about in scientific terms rather than
merely philosophical
terms. Uh, in recent years,
in the past 10 years or so,
uh,
there's been a kind of a
revolution in cosmology, uh,
which has come about because of the
discovery that the vast majority of the
universe is made out of stuff,
uh,
that we have no idea what it is. So, uh,
the discovery is we have no idea
what the universe is made of. Uh,
and that actually, you know,
it doesn't sound so good. Uh,
it sounds like this is a big
failure of science somehow,
but scientists are clever. So we
describe it differently. What we,
what we claim is that what has happened
is that we have discovered dark energy,
dark energy. What is that? We
don't have a clue. Uh, but, uh,
it's most of the universe and we've
discovered that it exists. Uh,
and so that's kind of
where we are right now.
And what I want to do over the next,
uh,
four or five weeks is talk about
the discovery of dark energy, uh,
how that was done.
And now that we know that it's there,
but we don't know what it is, uh,
what people intend to do about it. Uh,
and, uh, this is,
I should say only a relatively
small fraction of modern cosmology.
Uh, if you, uh, want to know about, uh,
many of the other interesting things
that are going on in cosmology,
you have to take a whole course
or several courses on this topic.
Such courses exist.
Uh,
I recommend Astro one 70 or two 20 if
you find yourself interested in this kind
of thing. But nevertheless,
this one particular discovery,
and in fact what I'm going to be
focusing on is not just dark energy,
but one particular way, uh,
that dark energy, the first way.
There are now other
indications that it exists.
One particular way in which
dark energy has been discovered.
And so it's a fairly narrow focus,
uh, that I'll be taken care of.
But that will be,
that will enable us to get a,
into some depth about how
this discovery was made.
So let me let you in on the
secret before we even begin.
Dark energy is something that you
can't see that's sort of it's name. Uh,
we've done this twice already, right? Uh,
we've discovered planets
around other stars, uh,
that you couldn't see the planets. How
do you do that? You look at the star,
the motion of the star. We've discovered
the existence of black holes, uh,
which of course you can't see.
How do you do that?
You look at the motion of some star
that is influenced by the existence,
the black hole. So what are we
going to do about dark energy? Well,
this isn't a hard to extrapolate a,
what we're going to do is we're going
to look at the motion of things that we
can see and infer the presence
of dark energy. And of course,
how do we look at the motion?
We look at doppler shifts. Uh,
that will be another
recurring theme. Uh, and, uh,
so the plan of action here is actually
not so different from something we've
done a couple of times before,
although the contacts and the
implications and the particular details.
Uh, needless to say, our, uh, okay.
So let's go back in time,
uh,
almost 90 years back to 1920,
1920.
So it's opposing one word to give a
course in frontiers and controversies in
astrophysics in the year 1920.
Uh,
what would one have been talking
about frontiers and controversies?
The big issue, uh, at least in
terms of, uh, uh, cosmology,
uh, was the question of the
so called spiral nebulae.
These had been discovered
over the previous few decades
after the invention of
photography, uh, allowed pictures
of the sky to be created.
And as people took pictures of the sky,
what they discovered was all scattered
all over the sky or these little spiral
clouds, the so called spiral
nebulae. What are these things?
They wandered and in particular,
where are these things?
And there were two basic hypotheses.
One was that these are sort of clouds,
uh,
shining clouds of gas.
These were known to exist in other kinds
of shapes, shapes. So these are, uh,
clouds a of some kind of glowing gas,
uh,
and that they are part of our,
so called galaxy galaxy comes
from the Greek word for milk.
It's basically Greek for Milky Way,
the Milky Way as this band of,
uh, stars across the sky. Uh,
it looks like just a white street. You
can't see it in the city with city lights.
Uh, you know, if you've never
seen this, go somewhere dark,
wait till the moon goes down, get your
eyes adapted and look for the Milky Way.
It's really very spectacular. Uh,
if you really want to do this right,
do it in the southern hemisphere.
Um,
because the center of our galaxy is down
there. It's quite spectacular. Uh, anyway,
uh, it had been known since Galileo's
time, but what the Milky Way really was,
was a band of stars. And so that there's
this huge bunch of stars out there,
uh, so faint, so packed
together. We see it just as he
continuous band of light. Uh,
and so all these stars, that's our
galaxy. Uh, and the question was,
these spiral nebulae might be little
clouds of something or other scattered
around our galaxy. The alternative, uh,
less popular at the time,
but perhaps more spectacular is that
these spiral nebulae are galaxies
themselves. Our whole galaxies of
stars, different from our own galaxy.
These were sometimes referred
to as island universes.
So the Milky Way is our own galaxy.
And each one of these tiny little spiral
things is a galaxy itself located much,
much further away obviously than any of
the stars that we can see. And you can,
you can see that this is a question of
some important in particular to how beat
you think the universe is.
If all of these, uh, uh,
spiral nebulae are part of our own galaxy
than maybe what the universe is, is, uh,
is one galaxy.
Uh,
and at that time it was already starting
to be known how big the galaxy was and
so forth. Uh, but if each
one of them's its own galaxy,
then, uh, obviously the
entire universe much be much,
much bigger because it contains thousands,
perhaps millions of individual galaxies.
Each of them more or less like our own.
So we know what the answer's going to
turn out to be. Uh, this is correct.
But they didn't know
that in 1920 and in fact,
they staged what was called
the great debate, uh,
in 1920 between a very famous
astronomer named Harlow Shapley,
who was at Harvard, and he, uh,
maintained that the a spiral nebulae
must be part of our own galaxy.
Uh, and so he had many
good reasons to think this.
There was a lot of evidence that,
uh,
these spiral nebulae couldn't
be that far away. Uh,
they must be really quite nearby.
And so Shapley had in the
true Harvard manner, uh,
all of the right arguments
and was completely wrong. Uh,
and, uh, his opponent, a man
named Curtis educated at Yale,
but at that point were working somewhere
else, turned out to be entirely right.
Uh, but, uh,
but totally lost the debate because
he just didn't have that much evidence
backing him up. Uh, so the intuition
of the Yale man comes through. Uh,
so this is a famous incident
in the history of science.
Uh, it garnered enormous
attention at the time. Remember,
this is a year after the
eclipse expedition has
verified Einstein's theory of
general relativity.
So people are pretty excited about
modern science at the time. Uh,
and this was reported
widely in the press. So, uh,
this is another one of our sort
of science fables here. Uh,
the great debate
and one version of the moral.
This story might be a,
you can have all the right
arguments and still be wrong.
Have many a good argument.
Okay.
Uh,
and still be wrong.
Uh, as Mr Shapley, uh,
turned out to be interestingly at the
time in 1920, they thought, you know,
it's going to take us a long time to, you
know, really get to the truth of this.
And that turned out not to be the case.
Within just a few years after
the debate had taken place.
This problem was totally solved.
And the man who solved it, uh,
was, uh, perhaps the greatest, uh,
observational astronomer
of the 20th century, uh,
a man named Edwin Hubble after whom
a telescope was subsequently named.
Uh,
and what is,
what helped solve this was
simply better equipment. Uh,
and in fact, starting kind of a trend
that has continued for a century.
Now what happened was, so a Hubble was
out in California where there are nice,
clear skies and,
uh,
persuaded a and a rich man to give
a lot of money to build a really big
telescope. Uh, this was a hundred inch
telescope. That's the diameter of the, uh,
uh, uh, uh, the diameter
of the, uh, mirror.
This is actually still in use.
Uh,
although the site is no good cause
it's way too near to the lights of San
Francisco. But, um, uh, he
took this brand new telescope,
he looked at the spiral nebulae and he
did the same thing to the spiral nebulae
that Galileo had done to
the, uh, to the Milky Way.
He resolved it into individual stars
and he could see the individual stars in
these spiral nebulae and discovered in
the nearest stuff, thumb, uh, that, um,
uh,
that they were made up of stars.
And then you notice that the stars that
were making them up were incredibly
faint. And that even the brightest stars
in these things were incredibly faint.
And so he inferred the distance to
these things by assuming that, you know,
they're kind of ordinary stars, like any
other kinds of stars except they're way,
way fainter, and therefore
they must be much further away.
And this was compelling evidence that
these spiral nebulae really were island
galaxy island universes,
galaxies like our own. And, uh,
the key thing to do that is to have a
telescope powerful enough to resolve, uh,
some of the nearby examples
into individual stars.
So there are many galaxies.
And this was known
shortly after the great debate took place,
and that made the universe very much
larger than people had previous leaks
suspected because there are
all these galaxies around.
So Hubble was the great
expert at observing galaxies.
And so the next thing he decided,
he would look at you guys, okay,
now we know these things are galaxies.
Uh, let's check out there. You know,
he took doppler shift measurements.
He's trying to figure out
the motions of galaxies. Um,
and so he discovered a very strange thing,
namely,
that they are all going away from us.
Every galaxy he measured was
red shifted. Uh, and so by,
by the usual doppler shift
interpretation of these things,
they must all be moving away from us.
And Hubble went further and he created
one of the most famous diagrams in all of
astronomy, uh, in which
he plots red shift,
uh,
which is to say Z,
which is to say a radial velocity
divided by the speed of light,
at least in the Newtonian approximation,
which he was working in a versus distance.
So he figured out how far away
these galaxies are. We're,
he measured their red shift.
Uh,
and what he discovered is that these
things were very tightly correlated.
So if you plot each galaxy, measure
distance in a retro for each galaxy,
for a large number of galaxies, what
you find is that they line up like this.
This is the so called huddle diagram.
And it's basically the thing we're going
to be talking about for the next five
weeks or so is huddled diagrams
and what you can infer from them.
Uh, and, uh,
the huddle diagram can be sort
of summed up a in an equation.
If this is a straight line,
then it must be true that the velocity
of a given galaxy is equal to a constant,
which was given the letter h for the
Hubble constant times the distance.
This is Hubble's constant
and uh,
and,
and that just basically says in
Algebra what this says pictorially,
uh, that there, uh, that these things
line up in a straight line. Uh,
the Hubble constant is an
extremely important number. Uh,
you measure it by creating these huddle
diagrams and just measuring the slope of
the line. Uh, and the, uh,
primary scientific purpose of
the Hubble Space Telescope,
the largest and most expensive science
project ever created was to get an
accurate measurement
of the Hubble constant.
So all these beautiful pictures
you see are byproduct. Uh,
the purpose of the thing was to
measure the Hubble constant accurately.
There had been for many years a dispute
over what the correct value was.
This was resolved by the space telescope
and other things within the past decade.
Uh, and this was a big success. We
now know what the Hubble constant is.
It's measured in somewhat
weird unit. Uh, it's, uh,
70 or so kilometers per second,
per mega parsec.
All right, now let's pause
there for just a moment. Uh,
you could see why they use this
peculiar unit, uh, because you want it,
they're measuring velocity
in kilometers per second,
and they're measuring distance in
mega parsecs. Mega of course, uh,
doesn't just mean big.
It's a technical term.
It means a million means
10 to the six parsecs
a parsec, you will remember it's
about three light years, uh,
or three times 10 to the 16 meters or
three times 10 to the 13 kilometers.
Uh,
and so for each mega parsec
that it given galaxy as a way.
And notice now we've changed
our units from parsecs,
which we use for stars two mega parsecs.
That's basically the change in the scale
of the universe that came about when
people realize that the spiral
nebulae were galaxies. Uh,
so now you have to talk
about mega parsecs. In fact,
now we also talk from time to time,
I've got about Giga parsecs,
which are billions of parsecs.
Um,
for each mega parsec that
a galaxy is away from us,
it moves 70 kilometers per
second more away from us.
So something that's 10 kiloparsecs away,
uh,
ought to be moving 700
kilometers per second.
Something that's a hundred mega parsecs
away would be moving 7,000 kilometers a
second, uh, away from us.
And that's just an expression of what
this relationship is. Humble by the way.
Got this quite wrong. Uh, he, he, he,
he correctly a line to the mall up.
Uh,
but his value for the Hubble constant
turned out to be about 500 in these units,
which was quite wrong. Uh, and we'll
talk about that a why that was, uh,
later on. But now, but by now
with the Hubble Space Telescope,
we totally know this. Uh, and
that's a, an important result. Now,
this is,
this diagram and this relationship are
basically the key to what we're going to
be talking about. And so, uh, in fact,
this relates to the fact that there's,
this linear relationship
tells you several things.
It tells you that the
universe is expanding.
Sure.
Uh,
and,
and because of that, it
tells you that the, uh,
indirectly there's other evidence that
has to be brought to bear as well that
the big bang exist. So this is
the basis of Big Bang cosmology.
I don't want to talk about that right now.
We'll talk about the big bang on Tuesday.
We'll have a whole big
question and answer sessions.
So bring all your questions
about the big bang and cosmology.
We'll do that all up on Tuesday.
Uh,
what I want to talk about
now is much more mundane. Uh,
namely how do you measure these points?
How do you do this?
How do you create this diagram? This
diagram has these fabulous implications.
Uh, but in order to understand what's
going on, you'd better know, uh,
how you get the diagram
in the first place. Now,
part of it's clear, the x axis, uh,
we understand fairly well measuring,
okay
radio velocity,
okay.
Uh, that's easy. That's
just the doppler shift.
So that comes directly out of a particular
kind of measurement that you can
readily readily do.
Uh,
the y axis is the biggest problem
in all of astronomy. Namely,
how do you measure the distance to
something? And if you think about it,
that's what this great
debate was all about. Uh,
some people thought that the distances
to these spiral nebulae where a few
hundred or maybe a few thousand parsecs
other people's thought they were
millions of parsecs away and it
wasn't clear, which was right.
And if you think about
looking up into the sky,
looking at stars in the
sky at night, uh, it's, uh,
you can see where there's a problem. You
look up there, you see a bunch of stars,
and suddenly one of them shoots across
the [inaudible] guide to shooting star.
Uh, they don't, except for
the motion across the sky.
They don't look that difference. And yet
some of the, the, the fixed stars are,
uh, hundreds of light
years away. The planets,
which looked much the same to the
naked eye are, uh, you know, uh, uh,
a million times closer and that shooting
stars in the top of the atmosphere, uh,
and it's very hard to tell,
uh,
what the distances when you're
just kind of look up there.
And so distance is hard.
And that's, uh, basically, uh,
the problem I want to talk about
for the rest of today's class.
How do you measure distances?
Yes.
You said,
how do we know what the original,
oh, so how do you know what
the original wavelength was?
You make the assumption that,
uh,
atomic physics and chemistry are the
same in the distant galaxies as they are
here,
and therefore hydrogen should emit lines
at the same frequency as they do in the
atmosphere. Now, uh,
one of the things you can do if you
don't like what the cosmological
implications of things is you can say,
well, rather than interpreting this as,
as cosmology, let's just say that
in distant portions of the universe,
physics is different. If
you go down that road, uh,
you can get any answer you want.
Uh,
and this has been seriously
discussed from time to time. Um,
right?
So how do you measure distance?
That's the key.
Well,
there's one and only one kind of direct
where you could imagine doing this.
Here's The sun,
here's the earth going around the sun.
Uh, earth. Uh, here is, uh,
a nearby star
and here are a bunch of other
much further away stars.
They were all scattered around the
sky and you observe this nearby star,
uh, during the course of the year. As the
year goes on, you observe it repeatedly.
You observe it from here, for example.
Uh, and when you observe it from here,
it's in this direction.
Whoops, it's in this direction.
And therefore it appears to be in that
position relative to the other stars.
Whereas when you observe
it here, uh, it's,
uh, in a little bit of a different
position with respect to the other stars.
It looks like it's here.
And so if you observe this star
repeatedly over the course of the year,
it appears to move back and forth against
the background of the other stars.
Yeah,
this is a triangle. A, we know
what to do about triangles.
You can measure this angle,
uh,
because that's just the angular separation
of the two apparent positions of this
star in the sky.
We know this distance.
That's one astronomical unit because
this is the earth going around the sun.
Uh, and then what we want to know
is the distance to this star d,
uh, let's call that d one. And we
know the equation for this already.
We've done this before. This is
Alpha equals [inaudible] over d one,
uh,
where uh,
d two in this case is exactly
one astronomical unit.
And you may recall that if you measure
this in arc seconds and you measure this
in parsecs and you measure this in a,
you a,
you get a consistent set
of answers. Uh, and so, uh,
uh,
one the way it works out is
one over Alpha in arc seconds
equals the distance in parsecs.
And the reason that works is because d
two by this method is always equal to one
astronomical unit. If you
try this on Jupiter, uh,
you have to account for the fact
that Jupiter's further away, uh,
this is called the parallax method.
It's common in surveying.
You know,
you look at the same thing
from two different places.
You can figure out distances by,
uh, basically trigonometry here.
This is it called the parallax
method. Uh, and a parsec.
This is the definition of
a parsec is one parallax.
Second, it's a contraction
because you measure an arc second,
and the distance, uh, is one part second.
That is the definition of a parsec.
That's why we use parsec is a distance
measurement because it comes naturally
out of this parallax method.
Uh,
and so that's a fairly direct
geometric method. And you know,
this is a surveying technique.
This is how this is a straight
forward way of getting the distance.
And the problem with this is that it only
works on things that are really nearby
because we can measure, you know, uh,
maybe a hundredth of an arc
second change in position, uh,
but no better than that.
And so you can only get measurements
of distances in this way out to a few
hundred parsecs
works to kind of maximum given
our current instrumentation,
uh,
of a few hundred parsecs.
Yeah,
but the center of our Galaxy
is 8,000 parsecs away.
These other galaxies are mega parsecs
away. We can't be measuring one,
1000000th of an arc second, at least
not at the moment in terms of parallax.
So this only works for the very
nearest stars. And that's why, uh,
there was all this confusion about
the spiral nebulae because you know,
if they were 500 parsecs away,
you'd never be able to tell.
So most other distance measurement methods
of distance are some form of what's
called the standard candle method.
So here's how the standard candle method
works. Uh, it's a three step process,
uh, part one, uh, you look
at something, you know,
how bright something is,
the bright something is,
this is basically a version of what
Hubble did when he figured out that the
spiral nebulae must be very,
very distant and must therefore
be island university's,
you know how bright something
is. In the case of Hubble, uh,
he's looking at the brightest
stars in the galaxy.
She figures they're about as bright as
the brightest stars in our own galaxy.
So he knows how bright they
are. A part two, you measure,
uh, how bright, uh,
the object locks
take a picture of it or you count photons
or whatever it is that you do and you
figure out how bright it looks.
Uh,
and obviously it first something of a
given brightness. The further away it is,
the fainter it looks.
And we know exactly how that works.
It's a distance squared thing. If
it's twice as far away, it's a fourth.
It's a fourth as bright.
If it's three times far further,
it's one ninth that's bright. It goes
as one over the distance square. Uh,
this is a well known fact. Uh, you can,
you can try this out with light
bulbs at home. Uh, and uh,
so if you know how bright it is and
you measure how bright it, uh, uh,
it appears to be,
then you can compute the distance.
Okay. Uh, and this is why it's
called a standard candle. Oh yeah.
So, uh, the way this is, how do you
know this? That's the big question.
How do you know how bright the
thing is in the first place? Uh,
and the answer is usually that is it
that you're looking at something which is
an example of a class of objects
like stars or bright stars.
Uh, who's a brightness is no,
that's why you use the
term standard candle.
Cause here's a bunch of things.
They're all the same brightness.
They all have the same
standard candle power.
Some of them look fainter than others.
The ones that look fainter,
obviously you have to be further away.
And if you know the true brightness
of this class of objects,
you can figure out how far
away any example of it is, uh,
have to standard candles.
Uh,
and the problem with this is this phrase
here as you can pretty clearly see if
you get it wrong,
if you make the wrong assumption
about how bright these objects are,
you're going to screw this up completely.
And that's what Hubble did.
A Hubble was looking at a, a
particular kind of bright star, uh,
and which he thought he knew how
bright it was and he was wrong. Uh,
and uh,
so he got the wrong Hubble constant now
because he used the same kind of start
in all his galaxies.
He got it the same amount wrong
for all these different galaxies.
So they still lined up, they just
lined up along the wrong track. Um,
so it was still true that something
that he thought was twice as far away as
something else was in fact twice
as far away as something else.
He just got both of those
numbers wrong by the same factor.
Okay. Uh, this brings us to the, uh,
awkward question of how
do you measure brightness.
And now we have to talk about one of the,
uh,
great impediments to learning astronomy.
Uh, namely the magnitude scale,
astronomers count brightness
upside down and logarithmically
and I am now obliged by my membership
in the astronomical community to inflict
this upon you. Uh, saw the magnitude
scale. This is how we measure brightness.
It's upside down in
logarithmic and to the key,
a numerical relationship, uh, that, uh,
works.
It looks like this.
If you subtract the magnitude
of one object from another,
uh,
that equals minus five halves times the
log of the ratio of the brightnesses.
Don't panic. Uh, alright.
The magic word here is help sheet,
uh,
which will be posted later this
afternoon. Uh, so this is a key equation.
So let me, let me just define the
terms. Uh, this is the magnitude
of an object of, of two
different objects. Uh,
and this is the brightness.
Okay.
Of the two objects whereby brightness,
I mean, something sensible,
like how many photons per second, uh,
do you get from them or, or, or, or,
or some other kind of a true
measure of how bright they are.
Uh, now, uh,
this is a somewhat awkward equation
because it's a relative equation.
It doesn't tell you what the magnitude
of either one of these things is.
What it tells you is,
uh,
the magnitude of one compared to another.
So in order to figure out
the magnitude of something,
you have to know the magnitude
of something else. Uh,
and so you need one other piece of
information to have this be useful,
which is that they have defined a
particular star to have magnitude zero.
Uh,
the star Vega
is defined,
uh,
to have magnitude
zero. Uh, and so if
you start with thinker,
you could figure out the magnitude
of any other, uh, given object.
Uh,
and, uh, uh, I actually,
this is now causing trouble because it
turns out that in the far infrared Vega
is variable.
Uh,
and that's kind of unfortunate for the
basis of the whole magnitude system to
turn out, to be variable. Uh, but
they've coped with that in various ways.
All right, let me pause and remind you
of some things about Logarithms, uh,
which you may have forgotten.
What's the definition here?
The logarithm of 10 to
the x is equal to x.
That's the definition of
a logarithm. Uh, so, uh,
for example,
uh,
the logarithm of three times 10 to the
two a is equal to the logarithm of 10 to
the one half.
That's three times 10 to the two is
equal to the logarithm of 10 to the 2.5.
Because when you multiply to the x by 10
to the why you get 10 to the x plus y,
uh, which is equal to two and
a half. That's an example.
More examples on the help
sheet, uh, just in general,
the logarithm of tent city x times
10 to the y is equal to x plus y.
Because when you add those
together, that's how it works. Uh,
the logarithm of 10 to the x divided
by 10 to the Y is equal to x minus y.
Again, because of the way, uh,
logarithms multiplied together, uh,
and the Logarithm, uh, let's see,
10 to the x rays to the nth
power is equal to m times x.
This by the way, is why logarithms
are so incredibly useful. Uh,
you should always do all your
arithmetic and logarithms. Uh,
you should just automatically convert
everything in your head into logarithm.
In fact, in the days before calculators,
this is how people used to do arithmetic.
This is how slide rules
work, I should say. Uh,
they mark the thing off logarithmically
and then you're moving back and forth.
Uh, and people, you know,
if you memorize like 10 logarithms
of a few convenient numbers,
you can do all sorts of calculations in
your head because multiplication turns
into edition, which is
much, much easier to do.
And so if you can convert things
into logarithms in your head,
then all you have to do is
add numbers. That's easy. Uh,
similarly taking something to
the amp power, for example,
taking the square root of a number or
taking the cube of a number or something
like that reduces down to multiplication.
Uh,
it's hard to take a square
root of a number in your head,
but it's easy to divide a number by two,
which is the equivalent
of taking a square root.
So if you're thinking in Logarithms,
all you gotta do is divide it by two,
and you can amaze your friends by
doing square roots in your head. Uh,
if your friends are the kinds of people
who are amazed by that kind of thing. Uh,
mine are, uh, and, uh, so I
recommend this to you. You know,
if you have to prove that you've
learned something at college, uh,
spend a half hour memorizing 10,
10 different logarithms.
Did that just blow people's mind by
taking square roots on bets? Uh, okay.
Uh,
or you can do problem sets
in astronomy one 60, uh,
for example, uh, Sirius, the star Sirius,
which is the brightest star in the
sky, uh, is about three times brighter,
uh,
van Vega.
So what's its magnitude?
What's its magnitude? Well, uh,
let's write down the equation.
Magnitude of serious minus the magnitude
of Vega is equal to minus five halves.
Log of the brightness of serious
divided by the brightness of Vega. Now,
uh,
anytime you see three times brighter
or 20 times fainter or any thing,
uh, of that kind, what you're
really talking about is a ratio.
If serious is three
times brighter than Vega,
that means the brightness
of serious divided by the
brightness of Vega is three.
That's what that statement means. Uh,
and so we can just plug it right in.
Five halves, log of three, uh,
cause cause a serious is three
times brighter than Vegas.
So that ratio is equal to three.
What's the log of three? One half.
Thank you very much. Uh, this
is equal to minus five halves.
Log of 10 to the one half.
You will remember that the
square root of 10 is three.
Uh, so, uh, three is also equal to
Pi. But for, for for Logarithms,
uh, the important thing is the three
is equal to the square root of 10.
And so this is minus five halves
times one half a minus five fourths.
Now the magnitude of Vega,
we know that zero,
so the magnitude of serious is
equal to minus five fourths.
This is what I mean by the fact
that the scale is upside down. Uh,
the brighter the star is, the, the lower,
or if it goes through zero more negative,
the number becomes minus
one is a brighter star,
then zero zero is a brighter star,
then two, two is a brighter star,
then five and so forth. Uh,
and so low numbers are bright.
The magnitude of the sun
obviously extremely bright.
When we look at it turns out
to be minus 26 and a half. Uh,
and uh,
uh,
the magnitude of the faintest star that
can be seen with the Hubble telescope is
about plus 30. So, which is incredibly
faint. Uh, and that by the way,
is why again,
why logarithms are such good news because
the entire range of things we can see
in this guy goes from minus 26 to plus 30.
Those are numbers you can get
your mind around. Uh, in fact,
the difference in brightness between
those things is a number that I can't even
pronounce. Uh, and uh, uh,
so much easier to deal with magnitudes.
All right.
Now
that has to do with how bright things are,
how bright things, how bright
things appear to be, or how
bright they are. But, uh,
remember what we're trying to do,
we're trying to compare
how bright something is
intrinsically to how bright it
looks. And this gets you into the question
of there are actually two kinds of
magnitude.
The intrinsic brightness of an object,
uh,
is something called absolute magnitude,
whereas the observed brightness
is referred to as apparent magnitude.
And now the astronomers screw you up again
because we have different symbols for
the apparent brightness, apparent
magnitude, and the absolute magnitude,
the absolute magnitude is
given a simple capital m
and the apparent magnitude
is given the simple small m.
And the problem is that you can't actually
tell the difference between those two
in my handwriting, uh, and
probably yours as well. Uh, so, uh,
this leads to untold confusion,
but that's the way life is. Uh,
and the relationship between these
two has to relate to distance. Okay.
Before we get there,
the definition of absolute magnitude
magnitude, you'll notice that in the
previous comparison of serious to vague,
I was talking about apparent magnitude,
how bright it looks in the Scott absolute
absolute magnitude is defined as the
apparent magnitude.
If the object in question,
we're exactly 10 parsecs away.
So the sun has an absent, an
apparent magnitude, as I said before,
minus 26 and a half. But it's
actually not that bright of a star.
If you took the son out to
a distance of 10 parsecs,
its magnitude would be
4.7, uh, so, which is, uh,
among the fainter stars you
could see in the sky. Uh,
and so the absolute
magnitude of the sun is 4.7,
even though it's apparent magnitude
is minus 26 and a half. Uh,
so it turns out, for example,
that the star Sirius, uh,
is about three parsecs away.
And so,
uh, oh, I haven't told you
an important thing yet.
We'll come back to this in a second.
The problem set problem.
Obviously he's going to be uh, how, what
is the absolute magnitude of serious,
but I, but I have to write down
the formula first. Little m,
that's the apparent magnitude
minus big m. That's the
absolute magnitude, uh,
is equal to five times the
logarithm of the distance over 10.
Parsecs.
Now notice what happens if
the distance is equal to 10.
Parsecs then you've got the log of one.
What's the log of one?
Zero.
Thank you very much because this is the
log of 10 to the zero log of 10 to the
zero is zero.
And so if the log of this thing is zero,
then right hand side is zero.
So at a distance of 10, parsecs,
the apparent magnitude is equal to the
absolute magnitude cause m minus M is
zero, which is exactly what the
definition was. So that works.
So example, serious. Uh, so how far, uh,
so what is
the absolute magnitude of serious?
All right, here we go. Uh,
the apparent magnitude we figured out
just a minute ago is minus five fourths
minus the absolute magnitude,
which is what we're trying to figure out
a five times the log of three over 10,
which is a third,
uh,
which is equal to five times
the log of 10 to the minus one,
half a three is 10 to the one half,
one over three is 10
to the minus one half,
which is minus five halves.
But that five comes from here. The
minus a half comes from here. Uh,
so m is equal to five halves.
Um,
let's see.
Minus five fourths is
equal to five fourths.
Uh,
and that is the absolute magnitude.
I'm sorry. Oh, oh, you
want me to do okay? Sure.
So we okay to here.
So,
oh a. Okay, fine. Um, luck.
This is actually an important point.
Log of a third.
That's what we're going to try and do.
A is equal to log of one over 10 to the
one half a one over one over 10 to the n
is equal to 10 to the minus.
And that's the key thing.
And so this is the log of
10 to the minus one half.
That then means that five times the log
of a third is equal to five times minus
a half is equal to minus five halves.
Yes.
Uh, there are no unit. Yeah.
Magnitude tutor. Just numbers.
Yeah.
Yes.
Ah,
well what I did w sorry,
I skipped a step to start from that.
Minus five fourths minus M is
equal to minus five halves.
So I multiply both sides by negative one.
Can I subtract five
fourths from both sides?
You got to keep the minus side straight
to the easiest way to make mistakes.
And this is to get the thing upside down
and lose track of where your minus sign
talk, which is really easy to do
because the whole scale is backwards.
So you know, minus five
fourths is bright, uh,
whereas five fourths is faint and so your
one is constantly getting these things
upside down. Be careful, uh,
look at your answers
to see it makes sense.
If some incredibly think galaxy turns
out to have a magnitude of minus 50,
that's almost certainly wrong because
that's much brighter than the sun. Uh,
all right, so now, uh,
now we can actually do a,
the standard candle method. Here's
the, here's the key problem.
Uh,
if you observe a star
like serious and you,
I don't know,
you take it spectrum more or some alien
comes down and tells you this stars just
like serious or,
or however you work this out.
If you observe a star
like serious and measure,
it's apparent magnitude.
Okay
to be 8.75,
how far away is it?
And now we're back to where we were 20
minutes ago before I started all this
nonsense.
Namely,
we're trying to measure the distance of
something which was the whole purpose as
you may recall.
Uh,
so how far away is it? Uh, let's see.
Em minus M is equal to five log d over 10.
Parsecs.
Uh,
the apparent magnitude is
8.75 a the absolute magnitude.
We just figured out his five fourths.
1.25 is equal to five,
log d over 10.
Parsecs and you'll notice I've chosen my
numbers carefully because this is gonna
work out well.
Uh,
this is 7.5 and I'm going to divide both
sides by five 7.5 over five is equal to
the log of d over 10 parsecs or 1.5
is equal to the log of d over 10.
Parsecs. Now what do I do? Yeah,
exactly. You have to take 10
to the power of both sides. Uh,
whenever you're stuck with
log of something and you
don't want the log of the
something you want the
actual something itself,
what you gotta do is 10 to the 1.5 is
equal to 10 to the log d over 10 parsecs
10 to the log of anything is equal to
itself. So this is d over 10 parsecs.
Uh,
and thus
it's 10 to the 1.5 30.
Yes,
10 to the 1.5 is equal to 10 to the one
times 10 to the half is equal to three
times 10 to the one is 30.
So 30 is equal to d over 10
parsecs add D is equal to 300.
Parsecs.
And for the person who asked about units,
which was a very good question.
This is where the units come back.
It's because there's this 10 parsecs
embedded inside the equation.
And so the unit of length comes back here.
And so that's how you measure distance.
You know how bright something is probably
by having looked at some other more
nearby example, uh, you
measure how bright it looks,
you compare those two things and
out pops the distance. So, uh,
this is done usually in the form of
what's called the distance ladder,
which we will talk about
much more in section.
So you'll get many more
opportunities to do this nearby.
Stars you measured the distance and
parallax from the parallax method.
Okay?
Then you find examples of similar stars.
Uh, you know, you measure,
uh,
the apparent magnitude,
okay?
You assume,
uh,
the absolute magnitude to be the same
as the absolute magnitude for things you
already know. The distance to you
assume the absolute magnitude. Uh,
Andrew compute
the distance.
This then gets you new.
Uh,
this tells you that you learned
from this the absolute magnitudes of
magnitudes of brighter things,
not just stars, but whole galaxies,
supernovae, all sorts of things,
brighter things which you can
then measure further away.
And just to conclude,
you can see pretty clearly that this
method is fraught with potential problems
because every time you go through this,
you know,
that's a swear word in science,
you're making an assumption and
that assumption can lead you astray.
And so the whole history
of cosmology since 1925,
using that work, uh, assuming, uh,
the absolute magnitude of things for which
you're trying to measure the distance,
so you can put them on the Hubble diagram
so that you can deduce the rate of the
expansion of the universe.
And thus its age and ultimate fate a.
So it all rests on this little point
embedded inside the standard candle,
a which will be discussed at great length.
Okay.
That's it for today.